so when reviewing classic or older
movies I figure in the final stretch
before Halloween it's only fitting to
review Halloween esque movies so we got
a lot to cover so let's go 28 days later
officially speaking zombies are not the
only bad thing that happens every 28
days just saying you just gotta love a
zombie movie that's directed by an
oscar-winning director a movie that once
again is also shot from a cellphone and
I'm pretty sure I'm gonna get heat for
calling them zombies people are gonna be
like it's not zombie-ism it's a virus
that makes you act like you have rabies
they're not zombies yeah it's a virus
that makes people ravenous out of their
mind and makes them crave and eat flesh
and their saliva and blood will turn
normal people like them and make them
ravenously crave and eat flesh yeah
totally not zombies
sorry guys in the mid 90s viral zombies
became legit offshoots of their undead
counterparts oh they are zombies now
there is a lot to like about 28 days
later before this movie zombies were all
slow like so now they are pissed
ravenous out of their minds with
adrenaline they got their nike strapped
on and they are running after you and of
course the virus was released because a
bunch of activists who watch Project X
one too many times broke into a lab
found a bunch of monkeys being
experimented on who had this virus and
they released him of course blame the
monkeys again and again and 28 days
later Killian Murphy wakes up in a
hospital from like a coma or something
and he's absolutely oblivious that he's
just waking up amidst the apocalypse I
mean the city is absolutely deserted he
has missed the party and he looks and
feels like the only person left on earth
he's like Will Smith in that movie with
five minutes of The Dark Knight in front
of it but then he runs into some
infected which like I said they run now
and he runs into a couple of survivors
now this movie has some good actors
before they were like anybody's has
Killian Murphy as the main character
mad-eye moody from Harry Potter that
dude from well I'm gonna call him Doctor
Who because I'm not gonna mention that
he was in GI Joe but we will forgive him
for being in GI Joe another reason I
like this movie is because it shows what
you can make on a low-budget I mean for
the budget of like a loaf of Wonder
Bread they made a zombie movie I mean
I've heard stories of them filming with
no permits and filming at night so they
didn't get caught and fine for it I mean
it's a real testament to filmmaking it
really is and it's it's it's intense
it's good it's a more realistic take on
the apocalypse brought on by zombies if
ever there was one that in Zombieland
kind of so I really like 28 days later
it's a little slow in parts but it was
cool seeing the zombie outbreak like a
month after it happened it's not like
Dawn of the Dead where it's like
happening that day so everyone's still
kind of figuring it out and they're all
fortifying and holding up waiting for
help I mean help ain't coming the
apocalypse is a month into it it's just
survival at this point everyone but him
has adapted and learned to deal with it
for the past month so I mean that was
cool I mean the thing that pissed me off
most about the movie is I got the
blu-ray and it looks no better than a
DVD I mean there is no high-def version
of this movie but like I said price of a
loaf of Wonder Bread so you know
forgiveness so if you're looking for a
cool place for Halloween like 12 hours
of just Halloween movies with zombies
and vampires and whatnot I'd say 28 days
later gets a shot at that because 28
days later is zombie tastic in that
realistic kind of way
Halloween ratings always fun so stay
tuned tomorrow for my next movie review
which I mean if you want a hint hint I
would call it the tale of three cheese's
it's all I'm saying
it's all you get if you know it you know
it if you don't know it you're probably
not getting it and be sure to check out
my classic review collaboration I did
with the schmoes from schmoes no comm we
did it on thee Howard the Duck they
asked me to do a collaboration then they
suggested Howard the Duck and that's
what I knew they hate me
just kidding they're great I put the
link below go check it out and if you're
new to my page and if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more than click right here to see more
[Music]